foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar human
proteomics from the operating rooms the
lab and back I am Sabrina lemus of
labyrinths and I'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labrads and brought to you
by somalogic to learn more visit
somalogic.com we encourage you to
participate today by submitting any
questions you may have during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
Send and we'll answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical questions here as well if you
have trouble hearing or seeing the
presentation I'd like to now welcome our
speaker Dr vineet Mahajan Vice chair for
research director omix lab molecular
surgery program Dr Mahajan you may now
begin your presentation
thanks good morning everybody uh it's a
great opportunity to speak to you about
what we've been working on in the
operating room and in the laboratory to
help improve patient care particularly
for eye disease but I think this will
apply to lots of different human
diseases uh that are have some surgical
aspect to them I'd like to acknowledge
members of my lab
collaborators and our funding sources
which are largely through the National
Institutes of Health so I direct
something called a molecular surgery
program and in the last five plus years
in Ophthalmology we have had remarkable
just really remarkable changes and
opportunities of how we diagnose and
treat patients from the illustration
here you can see we have the surgical
ability to deliver any molecular
therapeutic anywhere in the eye I tell
people we don't operate on tissues we
actually operate on cells we operate on
molecules so in the top left corner you
can see us giving it an injection which
is given in the clinic it's given with a
topical anesthesia it just takes a few
minutes
um and these days we're typically
injecting antibodies and these
antibodies against the vascular
endothelial growth factor for patients
with diabetes or macular degeneration
control angiogenesis that's happening
inside the eye on the bottom left corner
is a a needle this is a small 41 gauge
needle
and I was fortunate enough to be one of
the first gene therapy surgeons uh to
treat children with a blinding eye
disease and because we can precisely
deliver just a few hundred microliters
of a gene therapy Vector right next to
the target cells the uh in the retina
um
this turned out to be one of the first
FDA approved human gene therapies for
anything now one of the things that we
haven't done or taken advantage of which
is what I'm going to focus on today is
not just delivering molecules but
actually removing fluid and looking at
molecules so for example if somebody
comes into the emergency room with chest
pain we will draw blood and then we'll
measure a specific protein called
troponin if this protein is elevated
it's a sign that there's been damage to
the heart tissue and that the patient's
probably suffering from a heart attack
now we don't have these protein
biomarkers for lots of human diseases
but if we did if we had these protein
biomarkers this could help really inform
diagnosis operative therapy selection of
therapies post-operative healing design
of clinical trials and even drug design
and so as part of our molecular surgery
program here in our at the Stanford
buyers Eye Institute we're looking for
that biomarker to help us treat and
manage disease now there's a major
challenge in in human proteomics
particularly with with surgical disease
that I'll I'll talk just a few minutes
on how we've been able to address that
so this is an image of me in the
operating room we have instruments in
the eye this is a retina surgery you can
see the instruments going in and then in
the top you can see a little white tube
and as we're working inside the eye
removing fluid we're also infusing fluid
to maintain the the shape of the eye now
in virtually every single surgery this
fluid is removed and it's thrown away
which is a major missed opportunity for
understanding patients disease so what
we've done is set up a biorepository to
help collect these tissues now
the operating room is really designed
for getting a patient in and out safely
and doing the surgery it's typically not
designed for high level science and
that's the issue that we addressed so
one of the first things that we did was
address the question of how do we get
dry ice into the operating room how do
we do Advanced molecular biology during
the sample collection and so we designed
something called the morally or the
morable operating room lab interface
which is essentially a lab bench that we
put some wheels on and the drawers we
have sample tubes we have pipette men we
have a computer
importantly we have a dry ice box
and tubes everything that you would have
in a laboratory but now we can wheel it
in and out of the operating rooms so
immediately when we remove some fluid
from the eye we can immediately freeze
it and capture information
this also Inc includes getting the
patient consent in the pre-operative
area capturing
patient data and information and then
putting the tubes into a permanently
etched barcoded tubes that are safe and
appropriate for putting in a minus 80.
once this fluid is collected it's then
stored in a nearby minus 80 freezer and
we use a database to to track each of
those tubes in an XYZ system so we can
address the challenge of finding the
tube finding the patient tube with the
disease that we need which could be
months later and
um uh more more recently
we have now moved to a um e-consent
process where the process is entirely uh
electronic which AIDS in the efficiency
of the system
so I'm going to start with one of our
first examples so uveitis uveitis is
intraocular inflammation it's
inflammation inside the eye just like
you might have joint inflammation or any
inflammation elsewhere in the body and
like any physician we're challenged with
when we see this inflammation what's the
best drug to use
now I'll introduce you this is a image
uh microscopic image of a patient who
came in we're examining them in the
clinic and if you follow this beam of
light with the highlighted area you can
now see the arrow pointing to these
white dots these are clusters of white
blood cells and leukocytes indicating
inflammation in the in the back of the
eye now what was especially unusual
about this patient is that he was part
of a multi-generational family a seven
generation family where half of each
generation would have this kind of
inflammation inside the eye and half of
every generation would eventually go
blind this was obviously a genetic
condition one of the first things that
we did at the University of Iowa was to
Stage the disease
typically at around age 20 in the 20s
patients would come in with that
inflammation that I showed they would be
developing a cataract act and then shown
in blue they would have edema of the
optic nerve and retina we would call
this stage two disease and it looked
like any other kind of uveitis and then
within a decade they would develop
neovascular neovascularization
angiogenesis and in this pigmented brown
color we're showing degeneration of the
retina and photoreceptors this would
look like a genetically inherited
photoreceptor disease known as retinitis
Pigmentosa it would also start to
develop some early Scar Tissue on the
surface of the retina and then by age 40
they would develop severe intraocular
fibrosis
neovascularization and then a retinal
detachment which is shown on the far
right
this disease was named adniv which is
short for autosomal dominant neovascular
inflammatory vitri retinopathy we
eventually identified the gene for this
which is calcane 5. it's a protease but
even knowing the Gene doesn't give us a
therapeutic a clear therapeutic plan for
these patients
what had happened over time is they had
failed a variety of conventional
therapies for inflammatory eye disease
this included oral prednisone oral
Methotrexate
azathioprine infliximab and various
kinds of surgery
so what we started doing was collecting
fluid from the eyes as these patients
went for surgery now most of us are
familiar with a conventional Elisa test
a Liza test uses antibodies to measure a
single Protein that's shown on the left
now once we get into proteomics that
means instead of measuring one protein
we're measuring a hundred to thousands
of proteins and one of the first
platforms that we used was an antibody
array shown here on the right we're
basically antibodies to different kinds
of cytokines are spotted on the array
and if they certain cytokiner is present
in the patient's eye fluid it'll show up
as a bright green dot if it's absent the
array will look black so we performed
this for a number of our uh patients
with this inflammatory disease and this
is the data generated as a heat map most
of us are familiar with election heat
Maps where it's either red or blue
depending on republican or democrat or
purple if it's somewhere in between this
is a nice way of showing quantitative
data and so in this case if the square
is bright orange that means the cytokine
is very highly elevated and expressed if
it's dark black or or light green that
means it's low each row in this heat map
represents a patient at various stages
of disease and each column is a
different cytokine and so this is
remarkable and that now inside the fluid
of the eye we can now detect very
specifically
all the cytokines that are being
expressed in specific the eyes of
patients and then at specific stages of
disease so one of the first things that
popped out which was just remarkable was
that there was no tnf Alpha in any of
the patient's eyes so as I mentioned one
of the conventional therapies for
patients with inflammatory eye disease
is to use an antibody called infliximab
which is an anti-tnf antibody it's given
as an infusion to the patients
um on a on a bi-weekly or monthly basis
a number of patients had received this
anti-tnf therapy and they all had failed
at therapy it hadn't
um uh mitigated disease in any way and
now here we can see clearly in those
inflamed eyes those inflamed eyes are
not expressing the drug Target so why
would you ever give a patient a drug
when they don't express that drug Target
um in fact that's sort of the the
conventional way of treating patients
and uh in a trial and error method now
one thing that we did see was we saw
that there was lots of elevated vegf
vegf expression this is a cytokine that
is uh uh triggers angiogenesis retinal
neovascularization and hemorrhages and
what we saw and you can see on the far
right panel that at stage two and stage
three disease when the patients are
having this angiogenesis
neovascularization there's lots of vegf
being expressed
now at the time
um a uh antibody against vegf had
started to be used for uh macular
degeneration and diabetic patients that
had angiogenesis
um and so that seemed like an
appropriate drug to try now the normal
way that we would treat patients if they
came in with a bleed is that we would
take under surgery the surgery itself
would just trigger more inflammation and
then they would have a bleed later so
what we did instead of taking them to
surgery is we decided to reposition
avastin this antibody against vetchef on
the far left panel where it looks all
red shows a patient with a bleed inside
the eye their vision is Count fingers
they can only only see a few fingers
they can't read any letters on the chart
we gave an injection of avastin and then
two weeks later the blood started to
clear four weeks later the patient was
back to Baseline with all the blood gone
and the vision had improved to 2050. and
so with the knowledge of proteomics of
what cytokine was present we were able
to take what was normally a surgical
disease and turn it into something where
we could give an in-clinic injection of
of a specific
therapeutic against a single-cytokine
and make a significant change in the
disease
now one of the other things you can do
with your proteomics data is you can you
can take all that long list of proteins
feed it to software that begins to look
for Pathways molecules that are linked
to one another and what we saw here is
that there were a number of T signaling
Pathways uh being expressed in the
patient's eyes this correlated with
several of the histological analyzes on
the right you can see lots of CD3
positive T cells in the vitreous of the
patient eyes
um when we noticed two specific
signaling Pathways the mtor and the pi3
kinase signaling and so we began to ask
ourselves again was there a therapeutic
that we had on the shelf that we could
reposition that might Target these uh
specific Pathways
um and what we identified was the
Methotrexate now we've been using
Methotrexate injections to treat uh
lymphomas in human eyes
Methotrexate was known to Target the
mtor pi3 kinase pathway and what we
decided to do is when patients came in
with this inflammation that we would
give them an injection of this
Methotrexate and what the graphs show
below is our initial cohort of patients
is that immediately uh after the
injection within a week
the number of leukocytes or inflammatory
cells in the eye decreased dramatically
one of of the things that didn't
decrease or didn't change was something
called we call flare this is the
haziness or the fog in a headlight which
is representative of vascular leakage
that didn't change significantly but now
we had a drug that we could use to
control inflammation
normally we use steroid eye drops or
different kinds of steroids but in some
patients that'll cause eye pressure
issues we also use this Interventional
methotrexate injection
perioperatively before and after and at
the time of surgery to help control the
inflammation that occurs in these
patient eyes with surgery
now one of the ways uh that the patients
were being treated was with something
called a red assert implant this is a
surgery where we actually put this
little device in you can see the little
white circle there that looks like a
little aspirin tablet that's actually a
steroid implant that will have a slow
release of steroid over two and a half
years it's a way of locally controlling
inflammation without patients having to
take oral medications where a drug goes
throughout the body and has a potential
systemic side effects so now
interestingly we give patients steroids
and drugs all the time but we never know
what that actual uh drug is doing so in
this instance in the heat map here each
column is a a patient at different
stages of disease and we had patients
where we had
treated the patients with the steroid
and were able to collect fluid before
the steroid treatment this implant and
after and so this is one of the rare
instances where you can actually see the
proteomic signature of what your drug is
doing so in stage two disease what we
saw with the red assert the drug
treatment was that the T cells the
inflammatory cells went away in stage
three patients it actually controlled
the angiogenesis the the blood vessels
regressed and the development of new
blood vessels was less but in stage four
disease with their severe intraocular
fibrosis the reticer didn't have any
impact on that and on the right you can
see the heat map you can see all of
these cytokines that were elevated
before the steroid and then in panel C
you can see which of the steroids went
down we also collected data on steroids
rather cytokines that were unaffected by
uh the the treatment
so here uh one of the uh interesting
validations that we saw is that of the
cytokines that were uh present at this
stage four disease there were no steroid
sensitive Pathways and so frequently uh
in these two images you can see severe
fibrosis developing
um we call this inflammation and we
treat it with conventional steroids the
patients always failed this therapy and
now we had a good uh molecular reason
why they were failing the therapy is
that the the steroid sensitive proteins
just weren't there now interestingly
enough what we did see is this cytokine
interleukin-6 that was elevated in the
patient eyes and remained elevated even
after steroid treatment this is shown in
the top panel here where you can see
during the stages where there's more
fibrosis you see these bright green dots
for the il-6 you can see the tnf alpha
stays mostly the same and il-6 has
become them more and more popular these
days and has been linked to driving uh
fibrosis and patient patients in various
kinds of diseases so in the late stages
of patients with with this condition
once they had developed severe fibrosis
and had this retinal detachment which is
shown in the cartoon on the left and is
shown by ultrasound and Optical
coherence tomography on the right where
you have these retinal detachments these
are really surgically inoperable you
could spend hours removing all the scar
tissue reattach the retina but the
patient would rapidly develop Scar
Tissue again
so we we had a patient who was monocular
they had already lost Vision in one eye
and we thought well why don't we try uh
a surgery but also
um add a proteomics guided therapy
um and this would include uh anti-veget
Jeff to include treat the uh
neovascularization Methotrexate to help
control the inflammation but at this
time perioperatively in post-surgery we
would add an anti-isl-6 treatment and we
would reposition a toastilizumab an
anti-isle 6 antibody given intravenously
the arrows in this image pointing to
some of the scar tissue or where are the
edges where we basically had to amputate
um severely fibrotic retina but this is
one of the first adenivise not to
develop recurrent fibrosis and recurrent
retinal detachment after treatment
um and we believe although a single case
that it's really the molecular
Therapeutics that we added to the
surgical uh treatment that made the
difference for this eye you can see some
of the pigmentary degeneration you can
see some of the uh hemorrhages uh there
but but this is the first time we're
really controlling a severe fibrosis in
an eye and so I call this the additive
personalized proteome where we really
understand what's happening in the eyes
of these patients this is an unusual
instance where an entire family a group
of patients has the identical genetic
disease it's almost like performing a
mouse genetics experiment in the lab
it's about as close as we can can get
and what we learned is that we can treat
vitreous hemorrhages with avastin we
don't need to take the patients to
surgery we can treat inflammatory cells
with Interventional Methotrexate we can
delay disease progression with the red
assert steroid is not indicated for
fibrosis we can think about il-6 therapy
for fibrotic disease and anti-tnf
therapy is never really indicated and so
this is a big lesson to us about how
much we could learn from liquid biopsies
fluid that we collected inside the eye
by doing proteomic analysis to
understand the eye disease at a specific
time at specific stages and then going
after drugs that we have on the shelf
and intelligently and rationally
selecting those therapies now I'm going
to show some other examples and some
additional diseases that are not genetic
diseases and and how we've been looking
at using proteomics so there's something
called proliferative retinopathy this is
severe intricular fibrosis
um very difficult to treat several
clinical trials but we really haven't
figured out how to treat this and so can
we use proteomics to actually improve
our clinical trials uh this is purposed
um a few years ago these are photos of
some of the fellows and uh graduate
students working on the project this
this is a picture now of a 55 year old
has a grade C prolifter Venture
retinopathy and the arrows are pointing
to just really severe fibrosis inside
the eye and the way that one surgically
treats this is to actually go spend
several hours with tiny forceps inside
the eye try to remove all the scar
tissue and then flatten that retina like
wallpaper back up on the wall very
challenging
and not always a great outcome so what
we did is we played the same kind of
game as we took patients at different
stages of disease collected their eye
fluid in the operating room and then
performed different proteomic analyzes
on them again using a antibody array
what we show on the left is a is a
network diagram of proteins at early
stages of disease late stages of disease
and the proteins that really jumped out
in particular the mtor pathway and then
what we're showing on the right is is
what I like in the in the middle here is
the clinical phenotype which shown in
Black where it's well established how
doctors will diagnose and Stage these
patients going from retinal tear to
pigment deposition retinal folds and and
finally things called star folds on the
left is blue purple are the specific
cytokines expressed at each of those
stages of disease and then on the right
are various therapies that exist that
could be repurposed now interestingly
enough there was a clinical trial using
vegf and anti-vegf again and the trial
failed but what we found is that the
vetchef is expressed only at the very
earliest stages but the trial was
treating patients at the later stages of
disease so we think the reason the trial
may not have worked is that they were
using a therapy against a cytokine at
the wrong stage of of disease so
again we think steroid sensitive
signaling Pathways weren't represented
that steroid therapy trials have failed
in the past mtor signaling an il-6
targeting makes sense you could choose
serulimus you could choose those il-6
Inhibitors and probably a better way to
conduct clinical trials especially when
you have very specific molecular
Therapeutics is to enroll patients not
by just their clinical criteria but
whether or not they're expressing the
proteins that you're targeting or
specific biomarkers let's take a look at
another real uh common uh event in our
clinic and optimitus where we ask is
this patient's eye infected so this is a
65 year old day a 65 year old gentleman
six days after cataract surgery the
errors are pointing to this white fluffy
stuff inside the eye on the right you
can't see into the back of the eye it's
it's very inflamed now you don't know if
this is a severe post-operative sterile
inflammation we don't know if it's a
bacterial inflammation because of the
elderly patient and some other
comorbidities it could be any kind of
infection maybe a fungus maybe a virus
the way we treat patients these days is
we actually give them a full spectrum of
antibiotic anti-fungal potentially
antiviral we remove a small amount of
fluid and then we actually send it to
the path lab and we put it on a petri
dish and we wait for things to grow on
the petri dish to tell us what this
might be well what we did is collect
fluid from a variety of eyes
sterile inflammatory eyes eyes with
infections and you can see on the heat
map on the left there's clearly a
protein signature that can tell us that
this eye is infected or it's a sterile
inflammation and then in the Venn
diagram on the right you can see a bunch
of proteins that very clearly tell you
that this is likely to be a bacterial
infection it's a different kind of
signature if it's a viral infection and
a different kind of signature if it's a
fungal infection so I think in this
instance being able to capture some
fluid performing proteomics can really
tell us what we're treating very uh
rapidly as compared to
putting things on a petri dish so in the
future we're trying to validate these
biomarkers prospectively and we'd like
to develop and design an elazza for
Rapid diagnosis and potentially point of
care now in the Ophthalmology clinics we
also encounter cancer our most common
cancer is something called uvial
melanoma and like many cancerous
diseases we want to know is this
restricted to the eye or is this likely
to metastasize so with these patients
we've also been collecting eye fluid
and putting them under proteomic
analysis this is our team here and in a
pilot study we collected tumors these
uvial melanoma tumors from eight
patients on the left hand panel are
photographs inside the eye and you can
see sort of brown dark elevated spots
these are the melanomas inside the eye
and what's typically done these days is
a surgery that will biopsy the tumor
directly biopsy the tumor which can
which will you know damage the retina it
can cause some bleeding those tumor
cells are collected uh they're sent and
what's really a great piece of work uh
uh done a while ago is that those tumor
cells will be sequenced for specific
markers to tell the patient help tell us
whether this tumor is likely to
metastasize or not well we wanted to
test the hypothesis with that tumor
inside the eye it's probably affecting
the proteome the different proteins
being expressed inside the back of the
eye inside the vitreous and that's shown
in this cartoon now a lot of the
proteins that are in the eye really stay
sequestered in the eye but they might
leak out into the eye into the blood but
they would be heavily diluted so what we
did is we collected samples uh of the
vitreous fluid
um uh from from these tumors when they
were undergoing biopsy to see if we
could identify biomarkers that gave us
similar information Nation now what
we're showing here in these heat maps
are patients classified by the gene
expression in the tumor and panel a this
is called gep class and Class 2 patients
shown on the far right are patients that
are more likely to have
metastatic disease where that melanoma
escapes the eye and what we found that's
circled in red here is there's a very
significant protein signature that
correlates with that class II disease so
maybe it's possible that we can identify
proteins and not have to directly
biopsy the tumor itself but just collect
some of the fluid around it another
signature that tells us gene expression
signature that can tell us if it's
likely to metastasize is something
called the prime status and tumors that
are primed positive are more likely to
metastasize
um and you can see that there again is a
pretty clear signature of a series of
proteins that correlates with that gene
expression pattern and then finally like
we we did in some of our first cases we
can identify very specific uh proteins
where there are pre-existing drugs and
consider rational
anti-tumor therapy uh for for patients
depending on whether they're expressing
these specific targets
um
so
um for our proteomics signature for
melanoma here we really feel that we can
probably distinguish these molecular
classes with a simpler procedure C kit
and cement are potential targets for
drug repositioning
and now we're looking at the blood and a
different fluid chamber that we think
may give us a similar information
so uh let me switch gears now to some of
the work that's been done uh by Julian
wolf a postdoctoral fellow in in the lab
um and uh now looking at high resolution
proteomic profiling
so
the the images and and studies that I've
been showing you up until now are uh
we've been biopsying uh the vitreous
fluid compartment during surgery as a
retina surgeon if the patient comes into
the operating room this is the kind of
fluid that we're typically able to get
and when we remove that fluid from the
eye it's a it's a chamber that includes
about four CC's or four milliliters of
fluid and we can get about a half to one
cc of fluid which is sufficient for mass
spectrometry and sufficient for some of
the um arrays these antibody arrays that
I showed you
um but it turns out that there's this
front of the eye fluid it's called the
aqueous humor and in this cartoon that
that chamber is highlighted in yellow we
can insert a small 31 gauge needle the
fluid in that chamber is about 200 150
microliters and we can remove about 100
microliters safely so it's a much
smaller volume of of fluid than we were
getting from the back of the eye
but it's a lot more accessible we can
remove this fluid pretty easily in the
clinic you don't need to go to the
operating room but one of the real
challenges here is the the low volume
that we're collecting
um there is a low level of protein
concentration there are no cells there
but like I said it's easier to access so
one of the most common questions that
I'll get is that after showing data for
back of the eye the vitreous fluid
people will ask can you find that same
information in the front of the eye for
front of the eye uh uh fluid capture
um and so uh you know one of the most
common techniques of course for
proteomics is using mass spectrometry
um and the question is could we use this
in the aqueous humor and so we had
collected
um liquid biopsies from three patients
while undergoing cataract surgery and
the aqueous humor like the blood has
lots of albumin and has lots of
immunoglobulin and other proteins that
can obscure uh the more interesting
proteins when you're doing Mass
spectrometry
um so we wanted to test different
depletion methods so we collected the
fluid performed protein depletion and
then uh used Mass spectrometry
um and what we found is that basically
mass spectromically mass spectrometry
could detect about 117 proteins in in
our hands we tested albumin depletion
albumin plus IGG depletion and another
common depletion method which removes
you know 14 of the most uh abundant
depleted proteins and you can see in
these Venn diagrams and the graphs
compared to undepleted uh mass
spectrometry that there was limited
overlap the depletion process actually
removed a bunch of proteins that we
could see in the undepleted proteins
um and and the overall counts of
proteins that we would find were
generally quite low and in the bottom
panel in the heat map you can see how
how the the same sample The Identical
sample of fluid depending on your
depletion method had had drastically
different protein expression patterns
um and so we really felt this wasn't
um you know a great method although
though it's been been used quite
extensively and I'll I'll touch on that
um so the next thing that we we tried
was an aptimer-based assay and this is
from somalogic uh uh in their platform
to specifically look at aqueous humor
proteomics this this small volume and in
this case we had uh samples from eight
different patients
while undergoing cataract surgery this
is our we would consider this our
normative control meaning they they
don't have several of the diseases that
I talked about before they don't have
inflammation cancer fibrosis Etc now
what's what's interesting about this
aftermer uh based assay is that it has
over 7 000 DNA based aptimers these
probes to detect over 7 000 different
proteins
um so it's a ray-based but you know a
pretty sizable representation of the of
the proteome
um certainly compared to some of the
antibody arrays that we had been using
these aptimers are supposed to be highly
specific
um and and a pretty large library
and they have a been optimized for quite
an impressive detection range from the
femtamolar to micromolar for for
specific proteins purported to have low
variation
um and this gave us a platform to using
a a small volume of 50 micro 55
microliters at the lowest volume which
is some things we could certainly
capture in our aqueous humor samples and
there's a cartoon of this uh aptimer
array or how aptimer after Pro aptimers
are used to to capture uh proteins
um and so I'm just going to show some of
the the preliminary data that we have
and so on the left is a is a heat map
and this is quite remarkable uh to us so
these are eight patients uh males and
females ranging in age from 51 to 88
coming in for for cataract surgery
um and in in the top half you can see of
that heat map we could detect about 2
700 proteins in all eight of the
patients
um this is an eight-fold increase in
what we were able to see with our Mass
spectrometer entry methods and our array
methods are you know have up to a
thousand proteins just on the array but
this was 2 700 proteins that we could
detect
um uh in these patients below that you
can see another 2 000 proteins that vary
uh between patients and then finally 1
400 proteins on the array but where none
of the proteins were identified in any
of these samples now on the right
what we did is uh we did a literature
search on all the aqueous humor
proteomics previously uh published uh in
the gray Circle
um in comparative controls there have
been up to 321 unique proteins detected
um in the right in this purple blue
purple color
um there's 1700 aqueous humor proteins
in the literature that have been
detected in different kinds of diseases
on all sorts of different platforms
whether it's lcms or DNA labeled or
antibody assays but in this semologic
DNA Optima array
shown in green we were able to detect
close to 2 000 proteins in these normal
eyes that had never been described or
detected before
um the the physiology and the biology of
what that aqueous humor fluid does is is
not entirely known we know some of the
physiological outcomes or purposes for
example this is an immune privileged
tissue but we've never really known what
are the proteins circulating
um uh in there now the abdom array did
detect some of the several you can see
in the Venn diagram the overlapping
areas proteins that had previously been
described either in control samples or
or disease but but right now we think
this is probably one of the best ways to
explore protein expression in the
aqueous humor now one of the other
questions that I typically get is you
know a lot of your diseases are
happening in the back of the eye and
that's why you sampled the vitreous
which is shown in cartoon form on the
left with that big yellow area and that
was all of the earlier disease data we
were presenting and they asked well can
you detect those same proteins in the
front of the eye because that's easier
to get and if you can detect proteins in
the front of the eye you don't have to
go to the operating room every time you
could follow potentially the same
patient serially particularly with those
cancer patients where you're trying to
monitor uh for disease so what we did is
um we took 12
patients where we in the same eye we
collected the vitreous fluid in the back
of the eyeshadow on the left and we also
collected the aqueous shown uh on the
right that small 55 microliter volume
and applied them to the DNA aptimer
arrays
um and these are patients again with
non-inflammatory disease not cancer
um but but we're having surgery for
um one of the most benign conditions uh
that we would say every retinal membrane
or macular hole which we use as a
comparative control what the Venn
diagram shows is that
um of all the proteins expressed in the
vitreous which is in blue 86 percent of
those proteins are actually present in
the aqueous humor
um and so we imagine that 86 percent of
those proteins are actually flowing uh
back and forth between the two Chambers
but almost as expected 13 of the
proteins are really unique to the
vitreous the vitreous fluid chamber is
actually a gel it has a collagen sugar
Matrix and there are proteins that are
presumed to be sequestered in that so at
least 13 percent of those proteins are
only found in the vitreous and if those
are critical biomarkers those 13 of
proteins would require a vitreous biopsy
and you wouldn't be able able to use
them in the aqueous but the vast
majority of proteins are actually
detectable in the aqueous and and I
think that's remarkable uh and uh and
exciting now one of the things that one
of the first things that we uh began
looking at uh using this platform are
age-related signatures and so certainly
um in in in scientific circles
understanding aging at a molecular level
and and how one could intervene since
there are so many diseases where we're
really the the biggest risk factor is
aging people have been looking at
specific protein biomarkers
um
a couple of those biomarkers are mmp10
and nrp1 and what we found is that those
AJ those molecules are actually present
in the aqueous humor and then the panels
and the graphs on the right can be
detected in the aqueous humor and in our
initial sample sampling here actually so
show correlation with aging on par with
um the the serum detection of these
biomarkers one of the really cool
interesting studies that as looking at
aging where they were looking at
cerebral spinal fluid in young mice and
identified something called serum
response factor which had was depleted
in the older mice and replacing could
turn the older mice and give them
features of younger mice as a potential
anti-aging therapy we could certainly
detect that actually in the aqueous
humor and that actually had a very high
correlation
in terms of our human patients here as
an aging biomarker we could also
identify several other biomarkers just
specifically the aqueous humor that uh
correlate with with aging
um and and now I think we can play the
the same game again of looking at
biomarkers in the aqueous for various
diseases that would help guide diagnosis
might help guide clinical trial and
patient selection could help guide
determining if patients cancer is likely
to be metastatic or not
monitoring therapies and actually
selecting best therapies and patient
responses to therapies at the molecular
level I think that's what we're looking
ahead to now and we can use the aqueous
humor at an extraordinarily low volume
and get really good good data for for
making these decisions so let me just
show my last slide here
um the uh the uh the challenge of the of
the pandemic has been the separation of
of everybody
um we're finally coming together in our
clinics and our operating rooms and our
Labs uh it was a time to reflect and
this is one of the slides I made this is
an extraordinarily complex pipeline this
is these are photos of the the grad
students the post-docs the surgeons the
technicians in lab
the bioinformatics the proteomics team
the team taking care of patients and
getting those consents and then a number
of the various faculty that we uh work
with again proteomics Specialists uh
clinicians and biofemanticians
um and I think if we can link our
operating room to our Laboratories the
opportunity to understand disease and
treat diseases extraordinary and should
really be a focus of what we're doing I
think the different platforms of
proteomic platforms that we have will
really allow us to tackle a number of
these challenging conditions and while
I've shown everything here about eye
disease I think this is broadly
applicable to to human diseases
particularly those patients that are
ending up in the operating room we don't
want to miss the opportunity to collect
that disease fluid and perform
scientific analyzes that'll impact their
care and treatment with that I think we
have time now for for questions so I
will
um uh pause there
thank you so much Dr mohanjin for your
informative presentation we also have
Claire Patterson with us now to help
answer any of your questions welcome
Claire we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar so if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
it's located on the far left of your
screen and will answer as many questions
as we have time for
so our first question I have here says
thanks for the great talk and there's a
couple questions in this one did your
team ever consider an untargeted assay
instead of targeted and second of all um
how were the control samples in the heat
Maps shown selected
sure so um we uh
we have used these three different uh
platforms and you know they all they all
have their advantages and disadvantages
so one nice thing about the this this
cytokine arrays is that they're they're
quantitative they're just like an Elisa
and so you know you can actually get
picograms uh out of it and one would you
know you can think that well you know
Path Labs actually run Eliza's all the
time and so if you if you wanted to turn
this into a clinically useful broad
diagnostic uh you know that that pathway
is pretty clear but it's a very biased
approach and so the original arrays had
you know a couple hundred proteins and
then now up to a thousand proteins but
you're only measuring those specific
thousand proteins and so so it is a
biased approach if you're looking at
inflammatory disease and you want to
know the cytokines it's probably pretty
good
um but but again it's highly biased the
mass spectrometry approach
um is supposed to be unbiased
um and so you're not just looking at
cytokines you're looking at you know
potentially the entire proteome you know
which depends on your mass spectrometry
machine and how you're doing your your
liquid chromatography
um and uh but it's not quantitative it's
semi-quantitative and there's different
ways you're looking at that uh people do
the the informatics for that so you're
looking at relative expression levels
and and originally if you find
um that comparison you know on those two
different platforms you will get
overlapping information but it can be
quite different uh uh uh for things just
because of the methodology
um and then finally with the somalogic
array
um I it it combines some of the better
aspects of both
um and that you know you're you're up to
seven thousand plus
um which is a pretty darn good number
for detection you know you're you're
getting close to the whole proteome
um it's more unbiased than the than the
Eliza um it's not it's still not fully
quantitative in terms of like an Eliza
telling you picograms and so uh so you
have that aspect but
um but it really allows you to tackle
low volume and so
um you can choose your platform and and
they all have their own strengths and
weaknesses
um it depends a little bit on the
question you're trying to ask
um and and frequently
um you know we were using this a lot for
Discovery
um you know your your validation
experiments will sometimes use a
different platform
um or or different ways and so so it
kind of depends the question you're
asking the disease you're looking at
um and and how you're looking at it uh
for for selecting the different
platforms
um but they all have their own strengths
and weaknesses and then finally you know
we don't take normal patients to surgery
um and so we always have to use
comparative controls in our comparative
controls for retinal disease are
typically
um uh patients that have something
called a macular hole or an epiretenal
membrane
um and uh in those instances you know
they do have a they do have some kind of
disease because they're having surgery
but the clinical features are are very
very different
um and that's the comparison uh that
that most of us have done and and it's
really important you know that what
we're doing with our databases is that
we really have deep deep phenotyping of
the patients we have very specific
stages of disease we have their clinical
data clinical Imaging so that when we do
put a group of patients together it's a
highly curated list of patients I think
that makes a a big difference in the
quality of the data that we uh that we
get out of of that
thank you so much for that answer
um the next one that I have given the
change in proteomic capability what do
you anticipate in the coming years for
example capacity cost availability
yeah I think um the the the my general
sense is you know over the last 10 years
the accessibility to different kinds of
proteomic technology has increased
dramatically
um and the you know the the costs have
come down uh dramatically
um uh the the challenge with human
proteomics is is always this high
quality sample collection and so if you
don't have high quality samples or the
patients aren't well phenotyped or you
uh didn't rapidly freeze the sample you
know your you know junk in junk coming
out
um a lot of clinical trials and clinical
studies for example you know have deep
clinical phenotyping but not this deep
molecular phenotyping so I think that
the challenge of just getting a good
high quality patient sample is is always
going to remain the same I think that
that hasn't changed I think we've been
able to innovate there
um and the challenge there isn't really
the science it's really the
administrative aspects of it
um the quality of proteomics and
probably one of the biggest advances is
the accessibility of data analysis so
you know the original data sets of
analyzing the data and then what you
could do with it was really complicated
um but but filling in that part of the
pipeline making the data analysis more
uh accessible having greater expertise
we certainly have a lot of expertise
these days in in gene expression
analysis rna-seq for example
um and I think the proteomics will uh
will catch up with that
um I think it's critically important you
know I always tell people you know DNA
is static so we've done a lot of DNA
sequencing the chemistry is easy
um like I showed in my first example you
know the patients have a genetic risk
factor but that that genetic risk factor
genetic component doesn't tell you the
stage of disease doesn't tell you the
severity of disease it really leaves out
a lot and certainly in the case of gene
expression again where the chemistry is
straightforward to measure
you know RNA and whether those genes uh
have been expressed the presence of mRNA
still doesn't tell you whether a protein
is being expressed and doesn't always
give you that Dynamic uh uh effects of a
disease uh in patients and so I think I
think proteomics is really incredibly
important for the pipeline that
chemistry is really complicated the
informatics are complicated but I think
all of those steps have become more
accessible you can see from this last
slide how many people are involved I
mean it's a it's a it's a huge Endeavor
to to run that whole pipeline
um but like I said earlier I think the
opportunities are are pretty amazing
maybe I can just just add a couple of
sentences for that um I about the
availability accessibility and cost as
well as proteomics becomes more
accessible which is fantastic I think
today's presentation is a a fantastic
example of discovery of our 7000 Plex
platform at uh Soma scan we do also have
additional offerings of
um disease or biological process
specific panels
um as well as the opportunity to become
kit sites where you can actually have
the technology uh on site within within
your institution or company so you know
summer logic is working towards that
accessibility and increased availability
of products to make proteomics more
accessible because we we do believe
um and today is a great example that
this is the way forward to to help with
biomarker Discovery and Drug targeting
awesome thank you for adding for that
Claire
um this next one says great talk thank
you are there immune possible drug
Target signatures that cross between ah
and VH that might have impact for sample
collection and therapy delivery
yeah so we're we're at the the very
earliest stages of really looking at
this aqueous humor
um and
um as as I showed in a slide that at
least in the you know what we would call
normalize these are patients coming in
for routine uh cataract surgery
who were selected because they didn't
have any other kind of retinal disease
for example
um so uh what we have to do now is look
at the variety of diseases to answer
those questions but I think that's
that's exactly the kind of question that
we're asking
um there are specific diseases where the
inflammation is really restricted to the
front of the eye and this is called um
you know anterior uveitis uh and and
again there's a diagnostic challenge
where in some instances this could be
due to a virus or could is it autoimmune
is it autoinflammatory in those
instances I'm pretty confident that
we're going to see pretty clear immune
signature changes that could be measured
to potentially guide treatment and
monitor treatment but but I think what's
great that that we've seen is for back
of the eye diseases and the vitreous uh
for for retinal diseases which is one of
the as our as our population gets older
and older these are some of the most
impactful diseases on you know Vision
impairing uh uh the the independence and
health of of folks over 65 I really
think that that our opportunity to
sample from the front of the eye is
going to show us inflammatory signals
that are originating in the uh in the
back of the eye so so I I think that's
quite reasonable
um and it's a matter of now of just
collecting really good quality samples
and and seeing what's happened the other
thing that that I didn't mention is we
we know that
there are changes you can see in the
retina that correlate with neurological
diseases in the brain and
diseases that are are systemic diseases
will sometimes show up
um uh in as molecules inside the eye and
so again we're talking about eye fluid
that I think it's not just proteins
coming necessarily from the vitreous
some of those vitreous proteins are
actually originating from outside the
eye and we may get some insight uh into
into those kinds of diseases
great thank you
um and I think we have time for just one
more question uh this one says is the
code you use for analyzes of the
somalogic data publicly available and
could you please point me to the
manuscript that has that
yeah we we haven't this is this is
unpublished really preliminary data so
so uh hopefully we'll we'll uh get it
out there
um uh for for things and and happy to
discuss that
um as that comes out and
um you know people are using this
platform to look at other kinds of
diseases outside the eye uh as well that
that are published and I think would be
pretty insightful in terms of methods
methods and analyzes and and findings
I don't know if Claire had anything to
add on that
uh yeah uh we have many Publications in
in different
and we do have a Publications link on
our website that has a resource of all
of those many of which
um do contain methodology
um and some of which do contain uh
publicly available data sets we also do
have some uh
software packages for for reading uh and
interpreting the Soma scan data which is
also publicly available to make it easy
for individuals who have assayed their
samples to be able to interpret those
results also
yeah I think the the analyzes of uh the
ability to get some do some basic
analysis and see what's happening has
become incredibly more accessible
um uh that that even if you're not an
expert bioinformatician that you can you
can get some insight pretty quickly uh
on those kinds of things
well thank you guys so much for your
time today and also your important
research
um we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor somalogic for
underwriting today's educational webcast
uh before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and
they're interesting questions questions
we did not have time for today there
were a few that went unanswered um those
submitted during the on-demand period
all those they'll be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration and
this webcast can also be viewed on
demand so lab Roots will alert you via
email when it's available for replay and
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event thank you so much until
next time goodbye everybody
thanks take care